so so this is a a good example you know
the story ian is is telling the talking
point about yemen
you got to be careful about your sources
and so i want to bring this back to a
domestic issue um that's really
difficult to talk about and this is a
story of amir lok
so we have this story from
progressive.org someone sold holding a
sign saying amir lock was lynched by mpd
on two two two two
twin cities protesters are mourning and
marching for a mere lock for those those
that aren't familiar this is the video
of a no knock warrant body camera
footage
police enter an apartment start yelling
within nine seconds they kick a couch a
man sleeping under a blanket with a gun
emerges holding the gun proper trigger
discipline and within a split second
he's shot and killed
now the challenge here is upon watching
the video
upon hearing the official story that's
come out it sounds like the police lied
about what happened the official report
was that they entered the home
the the person in question pointed a a
loaded gun
shots were fired
and then he died to make it sound like
this guy amir actually fired the cops
now we're hearing from the family he had
a lice a concealed carry permit for this
gun now we're seeing posts all over
reddit where they say why isn't every
second amendment advocate furious about
this where's the nra i mean this is a
legal gun owner sleeping on a couch a no
knock warrant he wasn't the subject of
the warrant and i'll tell you exactly
why
i don't believe you
now if this guy when i watched this
video my immediate reaction was this
looks like the cops were wrong this guy
was not targeted to the warrant he was
sleeping as his right with his gun
probably dumb but he's allowed to do it
he never pointed the gun at every
anybody within nine seconds they shot
and killed him just because he was
legally carrying a weapon
the problem is
left
you lie about everything over and over
again so now i see a video that should
have my blood boiling and i'm like
well fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on me you expect me to come
out and march alongside you over this
issue you expect people who defend gun
rights to believe you after every lie
we've already been through from the
beginning of black lives matter with
trayvon martin with what happened in
ferguson that i personally witnessed to
to uh ahmed arbory to uh george floyd
every single lie and the same lawyers
like ben crump are involved in this one
so i'll tell you this
i don't like it i watch the video looks
bad but i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait
because you guys lie all the time
non-stop and i'm not falling for it ever
again
nice one dude thanks for bringing this
up i gotta say i think you pretty much
hit on all the topics on that one and
i'm like all right moving on well no i
mean i mean look here's the bottom line
does he have a right to be able to
possess the firearm absolutely because
i'm a supporter of constitutional carry
i believe that it's not something that
should be provided to us by governmental
rights it was already put into the
constitution and i'll go a step further
and say it's an it's an inalienable
right for us to be able to have defense
however i gotta say as a person who has
been deployed multiple times who has
served overseas i can't say outside of
i've always had my rifle within a arm's
length away from me or i've always had a
pistol which is you know in the hole
something like that i can't say that
it's not a bit odd that a gentleman
actually slept
with himself in trigger discipline under
the blanket and rose so again not
commenting on it does he have a right to
do it absolutely has a right to do it
let's see what the actual research in
the investigation finds exactly yeah um
you know my thoughts on this along with
many other instances if you're an
american citizen i don't care about your
race you have a right to keep and bear
arms i love it i'm simultaneously you
know getting criticism uh over these
more so the gun rights thing because i
said every american has a right to own
nuclear weapons under the second
amendment because it says nucle it says
arms keep and bear arms nuclear arms or
weapons i went on to then say that we
should prob you know it would probably
very easily easy to amend that most
people probably want that change and i'm
not advocating for uh people to have
nuclear weapons but of course far be it
from the lying establishment media and
left-wing activists to be honest about
what my opinion was
so how are you going to criticize me
that i that people you know
they're saying that i i would not
support gun rights for minorities when
you're also simultaneously criticizing
me for saying people should be allowed
to have nuclear weapons no the issue is
this guy is allowed to have his gun he's
allowed to sleep he's allowed to sleep
with his gun and he's allowed to hold
his gun in his own home and i got to
tell you this when it came to brandon
taylor's boyfriend and they kicked his
doran that was found to be a lawful
shooting when brentel's boyfriend opened
fire on the cops if you kick someone's
door in and they're not aware of what's
going on in the open fire that was found
to be justified self-defense from a
legal gun owner so for this guy to be
killed within nine seconds of an unknock
warrant i think it's really really
really awful but i also think i'm
probably being lied to and so the last
thing i'm going to do is in any way
support people who lied before lied
again lied again and in all honesty
probably lying now you cried wolf too
much and i'm not interested in hearing
it anymore sorry did they say that he
pointed the gun how did they phrase that
i can't remember exactly what the cop
said but they said something like he was
an unarmed man was was seen shots were
fired and then he died because he did
point the gun at the ground he didn't
point it anyway he pointed it at the
ground no he didn't i thought he got up
and held it proper he's just holding it
forward
okay when they started shooting him it's
it's like he's laying on a couch and he
sets up trouble for sure and he's
sleeping with his gun he's probably
expecting something just in case
something bad someone comes in or
that's not relevant
it's not relevant exactly and to be
completely fair if you're living in some
of these cities like new york for
example where criminality has just gone
through the roof or chicago or any of
the rest and you live in kind of you
know a less affluent area and you feel
that crime is is a potential threat that
could happen to you at any moment
hey why wouldn't you have the right to
defend yourself look i'm one of those
however again i'm like you i don't want
to catch myself into this where we don't
know the facts we don't know the reason
for entering we don't know the guy's
background we don't know whether or not
the surveillance team had watched him
enter that building just a moment ago
and maybe he had committed something
earlier again i don't want to speculate
when there's actual continuing
investigations on things but the one
thing that is without debate
is that under the second amendment right
everyone has a right to bear arms and so
here's the issue i remember when the
george floyd thing happened and i made
like five or six videos where i was like
this is appalling this is a problem we
have with policing they shouldn't have
done this then the body camera footage
comes out and i was like boy was i wrong
the dude's fighting the dude's on drugs
the dude says put me on the ground
several times and then i'm like yeah i
think the cops did bad but the initial
reaction was i thought these cops killed
this guy now it's manslaughter now it's
like okay they should not have done this
of course we got you know murder
conviction out of that
then the almond arbory thing i mean that
is a glorious piece of deceit deception
misinformation that ahmed arbory was
jogging in that neighborhood is one of
the most laughable lies i've ever heard
he wasn't
and i don't even learn this
until we had on a couple lawyers who had
been following the case and they said no
the prosecution even said he was a
burglary suspect that's not in dispute i
was like wait a minute what that's not
in dispute the prosecution even
acknowledged that yes i was like wow
boy they lied to me that's all they do
he was jogging in work boots through a
construction site 20 miles from where he
lives yeah
but again though this is this this is
where identity politics works for the
left so that lie was going to be spun in
a way that was going to benefit them in
some way i mean it's the same thing that
right now i just commenting on you know
again identity politics for the left has
become their bread and butter i just
hope that the right doesn't get caught
in this idea of like trying to like
follow suit the reason i brought this up
following the yemen point is that we
hear a lot this talking point about the
crisis in yemen and i'm at the point
where i'm just like yo
unless i read it and research it and
know what's going on i just don't
believe it anymore hearing it from dave
smith is not proof positive well i did
hear this so no to be fair i did a bit
of research on yemen for an educational
cartoon we were creating about it and it
is really horrible i mean there are some
estimates from
data that's been extrapolated from
unicef and different historic studies
they've done on malnourishment in the
region that says as many as 85 000
children may have starved to death
become because of this and actually
that's like the midpoint they said it
was between
60 000 and 110 000 based on their
estimates well and bear in mind that
that there was already issues with yemen
i mean they were already at a risk of
running out of natural like fresh water
to begin with that was already a problem
but from a you know looking at it from
someone who was literally looking at
terrorism counterterrorism for the
longest time in the middle east and was
a analyst for over 10 years and looking
at these areas i can tell you if you
looked at the aqap
where the al qaeda arabian peninsula and
where the gulf of aden in those areas
started spiraling out of control
under the obama administration the obama
administration it was a small contained
pocket in aqfp he started launching a
drone structure and they started growing
grow and grow and growing and then iran
got involved started adopting all the
houthis and started getting these riled
up and then you started utilizing again
it's like you and i right if we got in a
fight i don't want to fight in my house
i don't want to fight in your house
because we're going to destroy something
let's go fight in his house that's a
proxy that's what iran that's what iran
and saudi arabia continued obama wanted
the instability absolutely we wanted
syria to fall so we could build our
pipeline
there's also a good argument to be made
that he wanted to placate uh the saudis
because of the nuclear deal that was
done with iran it's all very complicated
but i will say this it's true that yemen
was if i'm not mistaken the poorest
country in the middle east before this
began but that said placing a blockade
around them when they were already
having trouble getting water i don't
want to be absolutely egregious i don't
want to
completely divert into talk about yemen
i was just bringing up the fact that you
know we've heard that a lot and i'm at
this point in my life where i'm just
like
if an activist comes to me an activist
and says something about some place i'm
gonna be like dude you're an activist
i'm not gonna believe the reason i
brought up yemen is because we were
talking about making concessions to your
military it was kind of the conversation
about maybe your military opponents
because like you want that we want this
we don't really agree but we're going to
like look the other way for you you look
the other way it's a marriage of
convenience yeah we got saudi selling
our oil and u.s dollars around the world
guaranteeing that our us dollar still
has some value basically so they're like
our front but that's their front man and
if we betray them they're gonna stop the
issue is again
not to get us into a talk about
how horrible the sods are what's going
on with yemen the the what i'm trying to
talk about is how the media has lied and
manipulated us into foreign wars how the
media has lied and manipulated people
into rioting and burning down their own
cities and how they're continuing to do
it and we have the potential for a very
real riot right now i'm already hearing
scuttlebutt that there's potential riots
this weekend over what happened with
amir lok it's starting to get warm out
it was 65 degrees out here today
when it's warm people riot when there's
conflict there's thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time